hey Samuel leaves here happy Sunday
evening I always like on a Sunday night
to just sit down and answer on YouTube
as many questions as I possibly can I
get some really cool questions on
YouTube but sometimes I can't type the
answer because it just needs me to
explain so hello people 1 9 1 9 9 8 says
hi Samuel how do you find rent to rent
properties it's a great question we know
what rental properties are because I
talk about them a lot on YouTube how do
you find them so when you find it a
rental property I think most people's
problem is that they try and go through
an agent if you try to go through an
agent they pretty much always gonna say
no we don't do that I don't understand
that there's a saying that says if you
confuse them you lose them and agents
just get confused they feel threatened
so getting it I've written to rent
through an estate agent or through a
letting agent is pretty challenging it
can be done but it's pretty challenging
so it's the best way to get a rent to
rent is to go to a landlord direct there
are some websites specifically designed
for landlords to advertise their
properties themselves if you're gone
open rent credit UK you can go direct
and you can message the landlord direct
Gumtree
there's loads of properties on for rent
and for sale on gumtree where you can go
direct to the landlord spare room I mean
I go on spare room code that you can and
just text the landlords and say hey if
you're struggling to rent out your rooms
and you'd like a guaranteed rent or if
you're looking to sell drop me a text
back we can have a chat that's one of
the ways that I find ready to rent I
just go wreck to landlord text them call
them message them email them however you
want to get hold of them cool them
through sites like that another way is I
go networking so I'll go out and do
property networking events and say hey
if anyone struggling to rent out their
property or if anyone's stuck or got got
an issue with property I'd love to help
I am your property problem solver and
then all these people that have problems
you're gonna serve their problem now you
might be thinking well if they've got
problem is why would you want to take on
those problems well the point is that's
what business is business is adding
value is finding someone's got a problem
and then solving that problem because
you've got a skill that they haven't
that skill might but you know how to
rent it out on Airbnb and they don't you
know how to find and manage tenants
better than they do in their stock so
poke that's helpful hello people next
question is from Nick cash Allie hi
Samuel I'm currently an accounting and
finance
Juden taking my final year exams a
couple weeks left until my final exams
what tips would you give a student just
finishing from university who's
interested in becoming financially free
I think you've gotta just solid really
like I get a lot of people messaging me
that are 15 16 18 21 and they're in
there studying
you've just got to decide what your main
focus is right now is your main focus
studying or is your main focus becoming
financially free I mean I wouldn't want
to say to anybody stop studying and
stopped you know quit school to become
financially free because you've got your
rest of your life to do property what I
personally did was I quit my job when I
was 16 and I became financially free and
then when I was 20 I went to college and
I spent three years at college I went to
Bible College and I was able to really
focus because I was getting good anais
thinking for my properties it's like the
other way around
most people study work hard to get a job
and they get a job and then think all
this sucks on to become financially free
when was what I did was became
financially free first and then studied
not to get a job but for my own
enjoyment I mean you could work on your
exams and study and do all that and then
in your spare time just almost as a
hobby learn about property go to some
property network meetings attend some
viewings and do it as a hobby alongside
your studies you could wait and finish
your studies and then start property or
you could say you know what stuff it why
am i studying so that I can one day get
a job when I don't want a job it's
completely nuts I don't want to do this
anymore I do think I do you think what's
interesting is when you're a kid or a
young adult and you're studying you
spend so much time and effort and many
hours go into studying if someone put
that same amount of effort and just
studying about becoming financially free
imagine what would happen but instead
people spend that time studying
chemistry and then they end up going and
working at McDonald's like you don't
need to know about chemistry I mean jeez
it's crazy but I can't tell you what to
do it depends on what your goals are me
talking Mike my opinion would be forget
everything study educate myself about
property front becoming financially free
study about money study business and
then implement it become wealthy and
then just do what I want dad that loves
me so anyway hope that helps any cash I
lay on you shin okay on you shin cool I
Samuel what hardships did you face as a
Christian entrepreneur
that other people may not have faced
also on any particular Bible verses that
has helped you throughout your journey
many thanks on you yeah I did actually
became a Christian when I was 16 very
involved in my church and when I bought
my first house it was all good but as I
started to become more successful I
started to buy more houses I was missing
the stood in my church for a lot of
houses now that there was a concept that
if you earn more than you need then
that's great
rose I think that if you have the
ability to earn more than you need and
then help others but you don't because
of laziness fear or apathy then that
selfishness you know that's that's
that's my thought process what Bible
verses the parable of the talents God
gave people talents some of them buried
the talents and they were rebuked for
being lazy some of them used the talents
and God gave them more talent so check
out the parable of the talents if you've
got a god-given brain to make money to
do something you got to use that if you
don't use it this is practical as well
if you're Christian or not if you if
you're given a gift if you don't use it
then you lose it also oh man there's
absolutely I'll write a whole book when
I went to college I actually I said
Bible College it was because of this
it's because I wanted to I wanted to I
wanted to study ethics morals I've been
I've been a good person but also being a
business person and making good money
and and I grappled with all this and I
wrote a whole book and my books called
do the possible watch God do the
impossible did my dissertation on
biblical economics so there's a whole
ton of verses I can tell you but I
recommend reading the book is on Amazon
I mean ultimately when it comes to being
a businessperson if you're religious or
if you've got a strong faith and you're
thinking oh should I be doing this
here's what I'll say it's not about what
you have it's about what has you money
is a fantastic servant but a terrible
master so make as much money as you can
but do it with open hands and a generous
heart and do it ethically amazing
interest stuff says how to purchase
houses with a mortgage when many more we
to providers require one-year landlords
experience okay so I'm not qualified to
give mortgage advice but what I would
say is couple things firstly make sure
that you get a mortgage broker who's
really good because a bank could say to
you know we can't lend some people say
to make Hong and a mortgage I'm like how
do you know because I went to San Tan
there and they said no that's just one
lender a mortgage broker has access to
hundreds of lenders they'll look at your
situation it might be that you or your
you've got a bit of bad credit a bit of
an issue so some banks won't like that
if it like if you're getting car
insurance if you wanted to get car
insurance you can just Google car
insurance person you could ring up a
vivo or insurance company and you can
say can I get insurance then what say we
can't insure you sorry and you go I
can't get insurance or you go to compare
the market and then there's hundreds
that come up and then you find the best
of the cheapest and mortgage brokers
just the exact same so what I would say
is speak to a broker tell them your
situation let them try and find you a
mortgage if they give you bad news like
or you can't get a mortgage that you
want just yet
you want to get a hatch um oh but you
can't because what they're saying is
because you're young and you don't own
any houses you know anything really you
need it you need it one year buy to let
experience then just buy a buy to let
house just buy just do what you can do
and then in the years time then get HMO
oh but I want to HMO now will be patient
your property business is your whole
life sometimes people think I want it
how I want just just relax just do what
you can plan your life in that year
study property get your buy to let
property or get a mortgage host or do a
joint venture and then that way you can
do anything regardless if you can't get
a mortgage and you're bankrupt you've
got C cj's doesn't matter because you
can get a mortgage host and do it
together so that there's a whole ton of
ways but just get good advice I've got
one more question from Mitch ashan Matt
this is challenging mrs. Chan said the
man or Karen pretty great name hi Samuel
I have a question for you how you close
a lease option agreement or rent to
mainly the city such as London where
there's a lack of motivated sellers okay
rent to rent and lease options very
different it's the same but a lease
option you buy at the end and also a
lease option you're not so bothered
about the monthly cash flow because
you're gonna own it so you're getting
any appreciation rent to rent is all
about the cash flow because you're not
buying the properties they're quite
different I would love to have a look
around in different areas of England
however I'm 16 thus limited to London so
Samuel do you know any areas within
London where strategies you teach would
prove effective and lease option
agreement do I need to have a registered
company when I did the financial freedom
challenge in America and I started in
New York I quickly realized that in New
York for my strategy wasn't gonna work I
had no money trying to find motivated
sellers to secure their properties on a
lease option agreement
New York weren't gonna work so I like to
move an hour and half down and up going
to Pennsylvania in New Jersey that sort
of area and I did a deal so in London if
you've got no money and you're trying to
find someone to give you their house for
free on the basis that you'll buy it
later for the for the price of it it's
worth now it could be tough because
London has had a massive expansion I
know it's been a bit static if it even
dipped a little bit the last couple
years but from 2011 to 2016 a lot of
property prices in London doubled
massive expansion so prices are went
really high now they're probably going
to be a little dip in London so trying
to find a property it's gonna be tough
because police option agreement you want
to go somewhere where houses are bottom
down whereby there's been a big drop and
there's gonna be a bigger I wouldn't
even recommend doing a lease option in
London because if there's a house in
London worth 500,000 pounds and you say
I'll buy it before hundred thousand
pound in five years in five years I
think you will have dropped you won't
make any capital depreciation I don't
think in the next few years London's
gonna go up I'd be looking at different
areas and you say oh I can't cuz I'm 16
if you're 16 I've been looking to do a
lease option agreement in a different
area where there's negative equity
there's motivated salads but just do it
over the phone you have to go to the
house in fact if you did go to the house
I don't know your situation but if
you're 16 you probably haven't got any
experience you don't know what to look
for in ours anyway you're not going to
be any use anyway so you just do all the
work over the phone
secure the deal and then prior to the
completion on the lease option agreement
just yesterday on the house you'd have
to go there man I hope that's kind of
opened your mind up a little bit anyway
some great questions I always enjoyed
reading these and answering as many as I
can so we're going to be doing the same
thing next week on Sunday at 7 p.m. if
you have got a question for me a
niggling property question comment below
and maybe I'll read your question out
next week thank you so much for watching
subscribe share the love and I'll see
you next time thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]